hey francis are you a conservative yes i
believe in decency respect and family
values well i think we found a
conservative parliamentarian who can
take us back to the glory holidays who
is this church churchillian figure neil
parish mp for our american viewers mp
stanford member of pornhub
this is a man who stood up to the tedium
of modern politics by watching porn
during a parliamentary debate yes the
tories are back and they're sleazier
than ever none of this garden party
during lockdown rubbish that's not the
tory party we've come to know and love
hancock golf parish
getting the conservatives back to basics
exactly i want tory mps shagging whilst
wearing chelsea football kids doing
cocaine and nightclub toilets and
watching debbie does dallas while
deciding how many masks you should wear
do we know if he'll be punished yes he
could be expelled from the party and
even lose his account on small
governmentbignockers.com
he's had the whip taken off him which
he'll be devastated about as he loves
being punished for being a naughty
little boy
my faith in politicians are so low i'm
just relieved he wasn't watching
nonspawn chill out mate he's a member of
parliament not a dj at the bbc good
point boris johnson was obviously
disgusted by the man's behavior was he
yes apparently neil parish was watching
brunettes and boris only likes blondes
who tell him what to think
first time he said he was trying to to
look up tractors do you believe that yes
you do yeah i know what he was actually
looking for the tractor he was looking
for and i could see how that could go to
something totally different
[Music]
you